ich schalte zum Beispiel Tennis die
Stadt basketballische andere Sportarten
gibt es die ganze Zeit schöne Höhepunkte
bei Fußball passiert nichts da gibt's
irgendwie zwei Tore oder drei Tore in 90
Minuten ist total langweiliger nämlich
beim Fußball gibt es das dass man den
Orgasmus denn da gibt es das eine Tor
das ist selten beim Tennis wird die
ganze Zeit nur Pornos hin und her
geballert da gibt's ja nur Höhepunkte
[Musik]
das ist Fleisch und Bossard wie man
unschwerden
gern
du bist ja sogar Mitglied der deutschen
autoren-nationalmannschaft seit wann
spielst du eigentlich Fußball ich spiele
Fußball seit ich denken kann seit beim
vierten Lebensjahr und tatsächlich bin
ich jetzt 45 Jahre mit diesem Spiel auf
der Welt und es gehört nach wie vor zu
dem schönsten was ich weiß und was ich
tue konntest du vor vier nicht denken
ich weiß ich habe zumindest keine
Erinnerung daran und deswegen ist in die
schönsten und ersten
Kindheitserinnerungen wie bei vielen
Menschen bei mir tatsächlich auch mit
Fußball verbunden nun muss man ja sagen
vielleicht schicken wir das nach vorne
weg wir sprechen natürlich über
fußballanlässlich der WM im Katar diese
WM in Katar die ist unter Beschuss es
gibt die Frage ob man sogar boykottieren
sollte und über diese Frage des Boykotts
zum Beispiel sprechen wir dann in einer
nächsten Episode heute soll es jetzt mal
um die Faszination des Spieles gehen du
bist ja großer Bayern München Fan was
man an dieser Stelle sagen darf ich
verstehe das nicht bist du auch Fan
Freundschaft nein was wurde jetzt auch
klar ich gucke jetzt nicht irgendwie
professionell
ganz bösen Text über den Fußball pseudo
und was du nicht genau dass du nicht
Fußball gucken willst mit jemandem der
dann daneben sitzt nichts von Fußball
versteht und dauernd kommentiert das bin
ich das heißt du und ich wir werden nie
zusammen Fußball gucken Wolfram das
kommt nicht gut
du hast eine private Philosophie
Lesegruppe und da kommt ein Pferd dahin
zu sagt ach der kann den mag ich nicht
eine blöde Frisur das kann man zwar
sagen aber irgendwie hat man das Gefühl
die Person ist nicht so richtig am Platz
und das passiert beim Fußball halt oft
und das zerstört die Erfahrung
ich schaue meistens mit mit Freunden mit
ausgewählten Freunden weil das für mich
auch eine Erfahrung ist die ich nicht
mit jedem Teil
aber das führt ja das führt ja eief auf
dieses auf dieses Mysterium des Fan
Seins man kann ja sagen ist eine Art
simulierte Unbedingtheit man tut so als
ob es um alles ginge aber man weiß dass
es nicht der Fall ist und wir brauchen
Zonen in unserer Existenz in der wir
ganz eminent zu tun als ob und das Spiel
ist so eine Zone ich kann so tun auch
als ob es wahnsinnig wichtig ist ob die
Schweiz gewinnen oder ob Deutschland
jetzt Weltmeister wird aber man muss
natürlich und das machen die meisten
Fans auch das Spiel ist vorbei und man
geht aus der Zone wieder raus insofern
finde ich eine ganz schönen
intensivierungsmodus des da seines zu
sagen jetzt tue ich mal so als ob es ihm
alles ging und das Spiel ist man anders
dafür aber sag mal bist du wirklich
traurig wenn deine Mannschaft verliert
ich meine er ist das etwas was ich
wirklich ergreift das kommt auf die Art
des Verlierens an aber es gibt natürlich
schon Erfahrung wo die die mit zu den
traurigsten meines Lebens gehören indem
ich zum Gefühl habe dass meine
Mannschaft und zu Unrecht verloren hat
und das ist auch schön dass man lernt
dass man verlieren kann obwohl man es
nicht verdient hat
ich merke zum Beispiel immer ich ist
eigentlich den Torwart den Goli wie der
Schweizer sagen finde ich eine der
interessantesten Figuren weil man ja
immer weiß dieser Moment beim Penalty
schießen beim Elfmeterschießen der ist
ja so interessant weil man weiß
derjenige der spielt der überlegt sich
ja rechts oder links und der Torwart
überlegt sich auch rechts oder links und
man verpasst sich halt unter Umständen
oder nicht aber es hat viel zu tun mit
Zufall weswegen ja man meistens auch den
Goli nicht ausschimpft wenn er den Ball
nicht hält und trotzdem ist aber ein
Held wenn er ihn hält das will ich
irgendwie total interessant und man
sieht ja nur und das ist sieht man schon
am Torwart es gibt ganz verschiedene
Profile dessen was ein Mensch können
muss um Fußball zu spielen man kann
sogar sagen es gibt keinen inklusiveres
Spiel als das Fußball ob man klein ist
ob er groß ist Rechtshänder oder
Linkshänder der Fußball bietet für jede
Form der Menschlichkeit eine Position in
diesem Spiel das heißt es wirklich
maximal inklusiv und zunehmend natürlich
auch für Frauen das ist ja auch etwas
was wir beobachten dass dieses Spiel das
ein rein männliches war mittlerweile die
gesamte weibliche Welt erobert und nicht
nur in Europa sondern in der Welt
war sogar von der
Herrenfußball WM oder Männerfußball WM
spricht das heißt es klingt schon mit es
gibt auch die Frauenfußball WM oder EM
oder was auch immer ich finde aber
trotzdem ich meine ich habe extra hier
den Pulli an der
Frauen-Nationalmannschaft ich finde
schon also es ist natürlich dieser
gender Aspekt ist absolut wichtig also
frauenfußball ist immer noch unglaublich
marginalisiert die EM jetzt im Sommer
die hat man geguckt hat man übertragen
zu Spitzenzeiten aber die meisten
Meisterschaften überträgt man gar nicht
oder an der Randzeiten dann gibt es
immer die Schwierigkeit guckt euch mal
die Websites an auf allen großen News
Portalen fußballresultate zuerst kommen
die Männer dann sicher noch die Junioren
irgendwelche beligas und dann irgendwo
noch die Frauen also das muss ich schon
sagen Frauenfußball zu gucken das macht
mir auch Spaß und ich finde die haben
also von den wenigen was ich vom Fußball
verstehe ist ein sehr schöner Fußball
was die spielen ja aber ich meine das
ist ein Punkt aber leider geht das auch
für viele andere Sportarten genauso das
hat die Frauen einfach schlechter
verbaut werden weniger Aufmerksamkeit
entschuldigung das ist viel ich muss
sofort ich habe eine rote Karte zeigen
Kollege Kollege das ist ein ganz
schlechtes Argument das ist so ein what
about this im Argument man sagt einfach
ja das ist ja woanders auch so deswegen
ist es kein Problem das stimmt doch
überhaupt
zeigen
was spezifischer fußball ist im
Vergleich zu relevanten anderen
Sportarten beispielsweise Basketball
beispielsweise Handball beispielsweise
Feldhockey und da muss man sagen dieses
strukturierte Ungleichheit herrscht in
allen Sportarten es gibt keine NBA aber
das ist besser nein
fußball ist und sogar umgekehrt der
Fußball ist in der Relevanz Entwicklung
des Frauenfußballs weiter als diese
anderen Sportarten er ist eher ein
Beispiel dafür dass diese Transformation
gelingen kann aber eben ist trotzdem
noch zugeben es gibt kein anderes Spiel
wo man immer über die Spielerfrauen
gesprochen hat und lange nur über die
Spielerfrauen also diese ganze Methode
Debatte kommt jetzt im Fußball an
beispielsweise der Prozess im Moment
gegen Boateng ich möchte nur daran
erinnern die Idee der Spielerfrauen die
gab es nicht beim Eishockey die gab es
nicht beim Handball also ich finde schon
naja ich finde schon es gibt dieses
dieses matchistische an diesem Fußball
sehr lange sehr dominant es weicht sich
auf Gott sei Dank schöner Pulli hier und
ich gucke auch gerne Frauenfußball
gucken auch viele Herren übrigens wer
guckt ihr Frauenfußball ja ich finde es
auch sehr schön es hat eine eigene
Ästhetik was was man die mal beschreiben
kann im Vergleich zu meiner Fußball aber
du wirst dann Punkt auf den ich sehr
wichtig finde als globales Spiel als
Spiel dieser Welt ist Fußball ein Spiel
das sogenannte toxische Männlichkeit
verkörpert produziert verstärkt also ist
man im Fußball in einem schlechten Sinne
besonders männlich und das kann man
sagen dass ich da ich wollte
Homosexualität gilt das auf jeden Fall
beispielsweise es geht auch natürlich
von diesen matschismus von der ich bin
der Held ich kann das alles alleine
machen aber schauen wir uns das Spiel
mal genauer an das ist ein Spiel das
sehr demokratisches kein einzelner
Spieler kann es dominieren und wenn wir
die wirklich schönen
ästhetischen Spiele anschauen sind das
eher and eine Wesen von Pelé zu Franz
Beckenbauer zu David Beckham das sind
eigentlich eher zierliche fragile
gestalten die gar nicht diese starke
Männlichkeit haben sondern eher androgyn
in ihrer Ästhetik sind aber warum ist es
so dass dieses Spiel das ist ja noch
nicht länger als 150 Jahre gibt die
globale Aufmerksamkeit in einer
wunderschönen Form sammeln kannst was
hat das Fußballspiel was die anderen
nicht haben
und über die ganze transportiert
und Reisen durch Afrika du bringst den
Ball mit und die Kinder spielen und du
brauchst ja nicht mal ein Tor du kannst
ja auch zwei Pullis hinlegen es reicht
ja irgendwas
Golf kannst du mich einfach so machen
können
mit meiner Bruder Ausrüstung auch kaum
zu Recht muss ich sagen
aber jetzt das mit dem also was ich auch
gut finde ist wenn irgendwo Fußball
gespielt wird auf einem Schulhausplatz
z.B dann kann man einfach dazu kommen
Fragen darf ich mitspielen wir sofort
inkludiert dann sind es mal auf der
einen Seite 5 auf der anderen Seite 6
dann geht deiner weg dann sind es noch
vier und so weiter man kann kommen und
gehen ich mag zum Beispiel keine Spiele
wo man nicht ein und aussteigen kann das
macht mich immer nervös wir kennen
natürlich auch beim Fußball die Leute
nach 10 Minuten sagen ja
allerliebste Barbara schon wieder ihr
kennt ja die Leute nach fünf Minuten
nach meinem Fußball sagen auch ich bin
durstig ich hör auf mit den Leuten
spielt man nicht so gern das sind ihre
spielverderbert das wunderbar gemacht
das wunderbare fußball ist das ist ein
vollkommen einnimmt der Philosoph von
Kulturwissenschaftler Hans-ulrich
Gumprecht sagt das ist Verlorenheit und
fokussierter Intensität wenn ich Fußball
treibe und das ist für mich das schöne
du fragtest danach ich denke an nichts
anderes das ist ein mentaler Staubsauger
man geht vollkommen auf in diesem Spiel
sprichst du jetzt von Fußball oder von
Sex das ist eine ganz ähnliche Erfahrung
ich glaube tatsächlich dass beides
ähnlich sein kann aber was ist der
Höhepunkt beim Fußball das dass man
überhaupt nichts mehr den gibt's
nein keine Aktion habt ihr das nicht das
Gefühl ich schalte zum Beispiel Tennis
sie starb basketballische andere
Sportarten die ganze Zeit schöne
Höhepunkte bei Fußball passiert nichts
da gibt's irgendwie zwei Tore oder drei
Tore in 90 Minuten ist total
langweiliger nämlich beim Fußball gibt
es das dass man den Orgasmus nennt da
gibt es das eine Tor das ist selten beim
Tennis wird die ganze Zeit nur Pornos
hin und her geballert da gibt's ja nur
Höhepunkte wir müssen noch übers
Tippspielen sprechen macht ihr
eigentlich Tippspiele das ist ja auch so
ein neuer Sport eigentlich gibt es einen
einen Nebengleis Sport bei diesen
Fußballspielen dass es dann immer so
Tippspiele gibt ganz bei uns auf der
Redaktion ja auch schon macht jeder
einen Einsatz von fünf Franken und
irgendeiner gewinnt dann bitte schön du
darfst tippen was würde dir tippen
also so Grobi das lief werden die jetzt
auch noch ins Finale bis zum Schluss die
kaufen sich den Sieg auch gerne
also es gibt ein herzenstipp ich würde
es der Schweiz gönnen ich finde das ein
wahnsinnig schönes zeichnen
wo meine wo wo ich meine Nahrung bekomme
aber wenn ich jetzt ein Expertentipp
geben müsste würde ich sagen und das tut
mir sehr weh ich glaube wir werden
wieder mit Spanien zurecht dann haben
der roten Bestie die wird uns in
Langeweile
schießen ja okay naja ich würde jetzt
auch die Schweiz hinschreiben so im
Sinne von magisches Denken guck mal
zusammen das kommt nicht gut weil wir
schon rausgefunden das haben wir schon
raus
haben wir jetzt gelernt also sagt man da
Hop Schwyz oder was sagt man da UPS hast
du gesagt
also eine schöne WM wünsche ich euch
gleichfalls
ja und wir haben der sind der
Fußballfans oder Fußball wir sind
gespannt
mit der Dominik Giesinger
Religion hat mit dem Lilian über Fußball